welcome back everyone to my round seven
recap of the gibraltar battle of the
sexist tournament
this one i played the well-known player
grandmaster pia kramling
uh she was a captain of the women's team
and she's also the mother of well-known
streamer anna kremling who i've collabed
with a few times in the past
and this was a really fun and
interesting and strategic game
so let's jump into it it started with a
ready opening which very quickly
transposed into a queen's gambit after
c4 e6
i was staying in my my comfort zone i've
been playing the queen's gap declined
almost my whole chess career
and this is a position i've had many
many times and the main moves for white
usually are knight c3 or g3
but
pia played an interesting move order
here
bishop to g5 which i was a little bit
prepared for during the game
and uh i had looked at this position
probably for like 20 or 30 minutes um
the the morning of the game and i
decided that i would play a move that
i've never played before is d take c4
and the point of this move is black is
going into
kind of a delayed queen's gambit
accepted now i don't entirely know what
to call this opening
because it's not quite a ragozan
lichas calls this the queen's gambit
declined traditional variation
but
dtx4 it's one of the more
confrontational moves because
i'm already questioning how white will
win back the pawn
and if white wants to really test me i
think the most critical move here is to
play e4
and then things can get very tactical
very quickly i was going to play c5 here
and then there's a line e5 h6
and position can get really really messy
but i knew pia is a more solid
positional player
and
she didn't go into the the tactical line
but rather played a solid line with
queen a4
very clearly intending to
soon win back the pawn
i blocked the check with knight bd7
and then rather than taking the pawn
with the queen right away she played
pawn e3
and then recaptured the pawn with the
bishop and i actually had this position
on my computer screen a few hours before
the game uh so this was one of the
positions i was expecting
and uh i prepared the very simple
castling with the idea that now my
knight is unpinned and black is
threatening knight to b6 to try and get
the the bishop pair
so white essentially has to retreat
either the queen or the bishop and the
only move i looked at before the game
was bishop to e2
but pia played a very reasonable move
queen c2 same idea that knight b6 is no
longer a fork
and here i play a very thematic pawn c5
dc5 and here it looks most natural to
take back with the knights
but i decided to play queen a5 check i
thought this was a stronger option um
just gives black a bit more initiative
because after knight c3 i can take on c5
and hit the bishop also activate the
queen
the queen does i the bishop on g5 and i
thought black has a very simple plan
here after bishop to d3
i play b6
and simply trying to complete
development
improve my worst place piece on c8 and
if i get in one more move bishop to b7
uh my rooks can then come in
and i'll also be having some ideas of
taking on f3 removing the guard of the
bishop which is still pressured by the
queen
so already i was feeling quite
comfortable here
and then white played the move pawn to
a3
which it looks a little bit slow at
first but the plan is to play pawn v4
and expand on the queen side
i decided to just complete development
bishop e7 and then pawn b4 queen c7 once
we got to this position i should point
out that white does have a couple
tactical ideas
uh first idea i should mention is bishop
takes h7
which at first looks like it wins upon
because there is a pin
um with the bishop pinning the knight to
my bishop on e7
however if white plays this then i can
simply take back and after bishop takes
e7 then black just takes over initiative
i would have rook
f to c8 creating the battery and a very
strong pin along the c file
and uh as calculating a few moves
further here if rookie won
i would take take and then knight to e5
which essentially traps a bishop and
just creates too many threats for white
to deal with so this would be completely
winning for black
so bishop takes h7 does not work for
white
and then the other idea which
i'll admit during the game i had
slightly miscalculated
is um
is what happens if white plays knight to
d5
and i was very much aware of this move
and it turns out this is a blunder for
white
because of black's response
but during the game i missed the the
best response for black i was
calculating takes
takes takes takes and then it would be a
trade where white gets a bishop hair i
actually thought she would go for this
but then after the game she was telling
me she was looking at this line
and realized that in this position
black has a nice in-between move bishop
takes b4 and black just wins the pawn
here after takes takes
whites down upon and this would just be
better for black
so
both knight d5 and bishop takes h7 there
are moves that white wants to play but
they don't work tactically
and for this reason uh white had to find
a different move here
so she played rook to c1 which is very
logical reinforces the c file
however this did give me time to grab
some initiative of my own
and wasted no time here i took on f3
takes and knight t5
and even though i conceded the bishop
pair temporarily
i do damage the kingside pawn structure
i hit the bishop on d3 threatening
knight f3
and white has to be really careful here
um just not to allow things to
completely collapse and she started with
bishop takes f6
now i do have to be careful because if i
take back i might allow bishop takes h7
so i decided to take on d3 first with
check
and after it takes takes
position simplifies a bit but
we're beginning to see once the dust is
settling black is just uh having a clear
advantage here with the rooks ready to
come in white is not yet castled it's
also a bishop versus night scenario
where the bishop is probably a bit
preferable over the night
and there's a nice calculation here is
that if white castles
which looks to be one of the most
natural moves
then i have a way to win material pretty
quickly
is to play rook
a to d8
now during the game i had started my
calculation with rook fd8 which looks to
be a little bit more natural
however this would allow knight to d5
and after takes white can take back with
the queen
and unfortunately my rook on 8 is
hanging
so compare this to the other line if i
start with rook 88
then if knight d5 i can safely take
and if queen takes the queen's not
hitting anything on eight and i can take
on c1
and its black is going to be up a piece
and end after takes and takes
so going back
um i think it's useful to kind of
understand the tactical ideas in this
position
and and show that white had to be really
really careful not to just lose material
right away
and he or she played a funny move but i
think it turns out to be one of the best
moves
is king to e2
uh i like to call this uh delayed bong
cloud um just giving up on on the
prospect of castling and putting the
king where
it does look a little bit iffy in the
center but it is sheltered by the pawns
and white does try to connect the rooks
and get the
rook on each one to a more useful place
so i went ahead played rook ac8 and now
i have three attackers against the
knights and now really questioning how
white will will deal with the simple
threats of bishop takes e3
and here
pia made her first kind of big blunder
of the game
uh what white should do here is go for
more simplification
uh the best move is knight to e4
now this would allow me to get two rooks
for a queen
but if we had entered this line um white
can even take on f6
after takes
i was
calculating this during the game and
thought black is the only one with
winning chances
given that the two rooks can
and sometimes overpower the queen
uh turns out the engine just says it's
it's completely equal here after the
move queen d4
um now the the position would still have
some life and i would still probably try
and play on for a win but this is
definitely better for white compared to
what happened in the game
going back white decided not to
go for the the imbalance of material
and tried to keep pieces on the board
and pia played the move knight to a2
which i think was played with good
intention to just try and uh
get initiative against my queen defend
the rook the problem with this move is
the knight turns out to be really
misplaced
and black has a really nice response
here queen to e5
just avoiding any sort of simplification
and now having a really big threat of
queen
to b2
and the threat is actually queen b2
queen d2 and then just win the pawn on
a3
and it's really hard for white to keep
everything defended here as we'll see
what white played in the game was pawn
a4
trying to
just get the pawn to a
more secure square but still after queen
b2 queen d2 i had to move queen to b3
and now there's just too many targets on
the queen side and it's really just
impossible for light to hold on to all
the material after takes takes
rook c1 i was happy to take and after
knight takes and take on a4
and i was feeling really good at this
point because we simplified and i want a
pawn
and i'm not getting mated on the back
rank because my bishop does control the
d8 square
so from here it was a question
how i convert
the extra pawn
into a winning position and i will say
that it wasn't easy uh going forward
white put up a lot of resistance
and
i've learned from this tournament just
playing so many strong players that even
when i get
a better or winning position
it can still be really difficult and
take a lot of effort and energy to
convert an advantage into a win
but thankfully the position was pretty
safe to play and it was a matter of
making small improvements
so uh white here improved the knight
with knight d3
and next several moves were just kind of
natural improving moves brought the
queen to a more central square
i made loof for my king
i knew because i have a darts for a
bishop my pawns are probably best on
light squares
and there was a subtle tactical idea
here
when i played g6 i could say oh no my
pawn but if white takes the pawn then i
would
check the king and win the knight by
force
so a7 pawn can't be taken the queen has
to cover c2
so she played f4 here
and game continued pawn h5 pawn h3 both
of us were kind of just waiting making
small improvements king g7 king d2
and then here i
realized that because the king is on d2
this allows me to play nice move pawn a5
and uh of course it's a strategy
whenever there's two versus one
um from lock's perspective i want to
make a pass pawn on the queen side and
a5 accomplishes this because after takes
i have the nice in-between move between
c3 check
uh now covering a5 and then i take back
with the pawn
and uh yeah now i have a past a pawn
and knights are pretty notorious for
being clumsy defenders
against outside past pawns and i was
happy that my bishop is already
controlling the queening square
and from here i thought it was going to
be pretty simple to just gradually
advance the pawn
but
as we're going to see white still pull
up resistance uh pia played the move
queen to a4
uh still covering c2 blockading the pawn
and i can't easily play queen b4 because
the knight is of course controlling b4
so it's still a question how black makes
progress
and as we're gonna see for the next
several moves i just kind of danced
around trying to find the optimal setup
for my queen and bishop so i started
with queen c7 she she actually expanded
here with pawn to e4
which was a slight surprise
and
i moved back
now that the d4 square is no longer
controlled by the pawn
i do have ideas of bishop d4 or even
queen d4
so for this reason she played king to e3
and even though the king looks really
exploitable on e3
it's really not easy to attack because
the knight controls
all the the key checking squares this is
very typical whenever a knight is
just a square adjacent to the king it
can be a very very useful defensive
piece
so i decided to play bishop e7 here some
ideas of bishop c5 or bishop to b4
she moved back to e2
played bishop to b4
queen b5 queen d4
and uh here we actually ended up
repeating a couple times played bishop
c3
knight c5 bishop to e1 i moved back
i realized my bishop isn't really
accomplishing much on e1 move back to c3
she moved back to c5 so i had to be
careful not to repeat three times
otherwise that would allow her to claim
repetition
and uh i brought the bishop back to b4
she played knight d3
and this was the 41st move
so we both got an extra half hour on the
clock
and i played move bishop to d6
and
turns out that
after a lot of maneuvering
i finally found a really nice setup for
my pieces the queen is really nicely
centralized the bishop dominates the
knight on d3
and even though white still has
everything defended
it turns out that it's really difficult
to find a move for white
and uh white is pretty much in zugsman
here she spent the next probably 10 to
15 minutes
thinking on the next move like what to
do for white um it's really hard to find
a move because uh the king is tied down
to defending e4
the queen is tied down to defend the
knight so there's no queen digs a5
and meanwhile i'm ready to just start
pushing the pawn
and there's really no good active move
for the knight
i also point out that e5 doesn't really
accomplish much i would just play bishop
e7 and white is still in kind of the
same predicament
so after a long think from
white she played the move queen to b2
uh offering a queen trade and i was
happy to see this move because after it
takes and takes this is a pretty
straightforward winning end game for
black just because a knight constantly
has to watch out for the a pawn
advancing
and meanwhile i can make progress
on the king side i started here with the
move bishop to c5
aiming to optimize the bishop fully with
bishop d4 she play king e2
bishop d4
and uh unfortunately for whites if uh
only way to move the knight and prevent
the a pawn from moving is to put the
knight on a4 on the edge but now the
knight is completely dominated by the
bishop
and i continue making progress on the
king side play king f6
f3 and now g5
and here it's all about creating a
pathway for my king to get through to
eventually win the h pawn and make a
second outside pass pawn
and there's really not much white can do
here she played the move king d3
i put my bishop all the way back on g1
e5 was playing king f5 and after takes
takes
knight to c3 pretty sure she was hoping
for king f4 after which white would
get a fork on e2
now this might still be winning for
black actually but uh decided not to
take any risks played the move king h4
now the h3 pawn is a goner
and she actually just resigned in this
position
um because it's really difficult to even
win the pawn and also deal with the
issues on the king side
so i was very pleased to convert
the end game and not not spoil my
advantage
especially against such a strong
opponent
uh i think in this game the opening
worked out really nicely i was able to
neutralize from early on and then um
after one kind of slip up in the middle
game with this knight a2 move
uh this is kind of the key turning point
where things very much went in my favor
so i do hope you guys enjoyed the game
uh it was a fun one to play it was honor
uh just to play a player like pia
crownling so yeah hope you learned a
thing or two if you have questions or
comments leave them below
and i look forward to seeing you in the
next video